aircraft carriers in the Mediterranean a
guided missile submarine the US has
deployed military assets that it says
are intended to deter the widening of
the war in Gaza and protect its
interests across the region it has used
force in one of the latest incidents the
US Central Command said a warship
patrolling the Red Sea intercepted
multiple attack drones launched from
houthi controlled areas in Yemen the
houthis have declared themselves part of
the so-called axis of resistance of
Iranian allies retaliating against
Israel's war on
Gaza resistance leaders in the region
say that until the full rights of the
State of Palestine are realized and
until an outcome is reached in
confronting the occupation in the region
they will keep their fingers on the
trigger Iran's foreign minister was
speaking in Beirut where he issued yet
another warning this timeat threatening
the expansion of the war if the
ceasefire agreed by Israel and Hamas
doesn't
continue Hezbollah a main player in the
axis is already engaged in intense
exchanges of fire with the Israeli Army
along the Lebanon
Border in Iraq armed groups have
escalated attacks on US troops stationed
there and in neighboring
Syria but some believe Iran is trying to
avoid direct confrontation with Israel
and the US Iran wants an immediate
ceasefire in order to prevent an
expansion of the conflict potentially to
Southern Lebanon uh Northern Israel and
of course Israel's border with Syria
where Hezbollah is likely to be active
and that could explain the step-by-step
escalation along Regional front
lines the so-called axis of resistance
appears to be basing its strategy on the
time Factor relying on hamas's
resilience in the face of it Israeli
attacks and Global efforts to end the
war Iran's foreign minister highlighted
more than six weeks of what he called
heroic Palestinian
resistance but many warn Israel is not
showing
restraint we should expect a wider
escalation in the region not only
because of the unity of the fronts and
the fact that they have to defend um
their Ally Hamas in this in this attack
but because I think they believe um in
the next phase you know once Israel is
is done in Gaza it will turn its cannons
and and attack um Iran's thatw and
specifically hisbah and South Lebanon
guns may fall silent for a few days but
without political and security
Arrangements The Rules of Engagement
could change at any moment zah alaz
nakura Southern
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer